the area where Donald Trump grew up was
New York's hardest hit by coid 19 from
Queens to the White House people here
know only too well this virus doesn't
discriminate elhurst hospital was at the
epicenter of New York's outbreak perhaps
little surprise there was a sense of
frustration at news the president has
now tested positive he's acting like
he's immune he's a superhero he's normal
regular person at the end of the day
America's supposed to considered
superpower right right now doesn't look
like it just 6 months ago the scenes at
Elmhurst Hospital were described as
apocalyptic so overwhelmed with patience
refrigerated lorries were brought in to
store the dead you don't need to go far
to meet people here who've lost loved
ones and lost patience with the
president it's very scary it's very
scary and I think he should have been on
on a safe way of using his
mask why do you think it's
scary if if the president have coin it's
a bad outlook on everybody else I lost a
lot of people that I work with and
friends and family and I just think it
should been handled a better
way now with just a month until the
election the president's diagnosis
undermines a core message of his
campaign that America is through the
worst of the pandemic
in an area that's lost more than 6,000
people to coid 19 Donald Trump's
positive spin on the pandemic has
understandably not gone down well here
what we'll be telling is how his
positive test has received among sves of
Americans elsewhere who belied the
threat of Corona virus was being
exaggerated to hamper his
reelection in July Sky News met
protesters at an anti-masking rally in
Texas we've caught up again with Len
Swanson who's unconcerned by the
president's illness so yes your your
prime minister got sick but he's not
Donald Trump Donald Trump has kept
himself in better health conditions than
your prime minister did do you still
believe Corona virus is a hoax Len oh H
yes yes it it's a hoax it's a virus yes
but it's been politicized as a weapon
to strike fear in order to try to derail
our uh the Trump government so even in a
badly hit Area like Queens you can still
find coid Skeptics I I think they're
trying to do some sort of uh mass
population control and uh the best way
to control a whole bunch of people is
through
fear at a crucial moment in the election
cycle after one of the most testing
years in American history the president
Health has thrown the country into more
uncertainty Sally Lockwood Sky News
Queens New York